santé sa femme avoue que je voulais sur
chose à voir ensemble là il ya quelque
chose comme 21h 21h03 mais le jeudi
civile
la journée a été donc je voulais faire
cette vidéo beaucoup plus tôt dans la
journée mais franchement j'ai pas le
temps par yann à on va parler de la
nouvelle console que microsoft va sortir
d'ici quelques temps la project scorpio
alors je sais pas c'était entendu parler
je sais pas si tu as un fan de consoles
je sais pas si tu suis apte eu un peu
console la projet scorpio ce doit être
la console la plus puissante au monde
bien plus puissante qu'une ps 4 pro
microsoft a vraiment envie de rivaliser
avec so nice pour isoler son marché et
elle est encore au delà de ce qu'ils ont
fait avec la xbox world pour vraiment
proposer le produit le plus puissant du
marché le plus beau avec les plus belles
qualités graphiques tout ça en 4k et je
vais t'expliquer un petit peu je peux
donner les détails par rapport à cette
console qui a été annoncé enfin pas
d'annoncer officiellement quoi que
microsoft a fait quand même sorti une
vidéo sur son site tu peux aller votre
site xbox c'est une info qui est sorti
par digital foundry qui a été convié par
microsoft à venir voir cette ou du moins
les époques de cette console directement
il nie crosoft à balancer des infos pour
faire commencer un petit peu a parlé de
sa console pour susciter l'envié
l'intérêt et prenant effectivement il y
allait avoir une des nouvelles consoles
nouvelles consoles qui allait sortir
chez microsoft en 2017
youpi alors ce fait le pitch si tu veux
je te lis bénin j'ai pris quelques notes
j'ai griffonné ce qu'explique truc mais
moi j'ai 13 ans l'objectif visé c'est de
prendre le dessus par rapport à la ps4
pro qui vraiment positionne aujourd'hui
comme la console la plus puissante et la
microsoft ne peut faire beaucoup
durant une nouvelle version dont je
lisais beaucoup plus musclée que la xbox
world qui actuellement se re marche et
je te donnais les spécifications
techniques mais ces quelques secondes
des jeux l'objectif c'est effectivement
d'avoir une console de jeu en 4 cas dans
le salon de l'a4 capuron va pas être sûr
je dirais des jeux qui vont être en 960
paix ou en ou sur de la full hd qui va
être en quelque sorte ému les problèmes
sur la cage cap sur l'a4 cas on sera
vraiment que sur l'a4 cap pur tout en
sachant qu'il y aura normalement une
vraie continuité entre les jeux dé tout
accessoire de la xbox soit que tu pourra
utiliser sur cette nouvelle console pour
que vraiment tous les gens qui sont déjà
équipés chez microsoft n'est pas à se
rééquiper à fond puisse acquérir cette
nouvelle console pour profiter de sa
puissance et des nouveaux jets qui ont
sorti les nouvelles licences mais
pouvoir effectivement joué encore aux
anciens titres qui sont disponibles sur
la xbox moineaux
la sortie annoncée normalement c'est
probablement les adressant leurs sites
holidays 2017 holidays à mon avis avec
les vacances d'été
on pense plutôt vacances de noël donc on
pense que cette console devrait sortir
normalement en décembre 2010 cette
histoire de pouvoir avoir un nouveau
beau cadeau sous le sapin
d'autant plus que c'est je te lis
vraiment un très très beau cadeau parce
que elle devrait situer normalement aux
retours des 500 $ à la console a donc un
petit peu moins de 500 euros
quelque 150 euros pour nous le fera
quand même d'avoir un très très beau
cadeau pour ce faire
au soir du père noël donc passez
commande dès aujourd'hui parce que
c'était quand même pas devenu alors au
niveau technique on nous annonce
vraiment de la 4k en 60 images secondes
ce qui permettra vraiment d'avoir une
image déjà de très très belles qualités
avec une vraie fluidité donc un confort
de jeu un confort visuel quelque chose
de vraiment sensas si tu veux les
valeurs qui qu'ils annoncent et une
console sans limite la puissance à
l'état pur la console la plus puissante
au monde rien que ça alors sous le capot
qu'est-ce qu'elle a cette console est là
processeur 8 coeurs cadencé à 2,3
gigahertz
au lieu d 1,75 jr ce qu'on connaît sur
la xbox one une carte graphique
constitué de 40 unités de calcul
fonctionnant à 1172 mégahertz offrant
une puissance égale à 6 téraflops
rien que ça tu vois vraiment qu'il a
sous le capot ça va envoyer du lourd je
te le disais 60 images par seconde de la
grosse fluidité qualité d'image
exceptionnelle en 4k une bande passante
mémoire les 320 gigas octets par seconde
si tu te rends compte du truc ça va être
juste dernier un disque dur de 1 tera
octet ce qu'on peut retrouver me semble
t'il sur la ps4 pro c'était pas de
conneries normalement c'est ça un
lecteur de disques blu ray 4 capes
fatalement de la mémoire vive en 12 giga
octet autant dire que ça va oui des
faits graves et on part effectivement
d'un système à puce qui permettrait
d'intégrer exactement au même endroit
processeur puce graphique et puce audio
cette console promet vraiment d'être une
petite révolution
enfin la petite et une grande révolution
mais en tout cas une révolution une
console qui va marquer
cette fin d'année 2010 est avec des jeux
qui vont être vraiment exploité à 100 %
pour pouvoir profiter vraiment d'une
image extraordinaire pour l'instant je
crois que là vers a été un peu mis de
côté pour l'instant pas plus d'infos là
dessus j'espère que microsoft va nous
proposer de la vère je sais pas
peut-être si on peut avoir de la verve
en 4k ça serait juste génial pouvoir
continuer à aller dans ce sens de la vr
donc dit bois toi ce que tu en penses je
sais pas c'était un très grand fan de
consoles je sais qu'on a eu soin des
discussions quand on parle et il n'y a
pas longtemps de la nintendo switch et
on sait qu effectivement il y avait des
joueurs qui sont fans de puissance et
qui veulent vraiment des consoles
puissant pour pouvoir avoir des jeux
d'extrême qualité donc dis moi si tu
attends avec impatience et de consoles
qu'est ce que tu voudrais qu'elle te
propose quel type de jeu tu dois
retourner dessus et et du bois tout ce
que tu penses de ses différentes
caractéristiques techniques n'hésite pas
à tabou dhl si tu vas voir toujours plus
d'infos sur le high tech je te réserve
des nouveautés dans les jours à venir
jean louis pas plus mais tu vois rien
alors pas mal de nouveautés apportées
pas mal un vent d'air frais sur sur la
chaîne et même plus encore je te dirai
sans dire très très bientôt
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo pour moi
je vais fait dire en mon revers de
cocaïne et 21 ans et tu vois on a fait
court mais bon on avait peu de choses à
se dire
mais ces choses là était essentielle un
gros pouce bleus si tu as aimé n'hésite
pas à beaune toi la chaîne merci
beaucoup
j'attends avec impatience de lire tes
commentaires je te donne rendez vous
très bientôt pour te dire toutes ces
nouveautés
ciao ciao